the phone should feel great in your hand
and more importantly should be easy to
use with this magical device we all
carry called a horizontally opposed
thumb it should be easy to send messages
type emails and that's just how we
designed iPhone 5.
yeah it's pretty clear that Apple's
values are changing and we just got a
confirmation that next year they're
taking it to the next level with the
iPhone 16. yes both of the 16 Pro Models
are getting even larger displays
specifically 6.3 inch on the pro and a
massive 6.9 inch on the max so I'm gonna
answer three questions in this video why
are they doing this how did we get here
and what else is coming to next year's
iPhone when the iPhone 6 Plus came out
with a 5.5 inch display almost 10 years
ago it was pretty clear why at the time
it was honestly Market pressure from
competitors putting larger and larger
displays on their phones so Apple
quickly figured out that if someone
wanted a big screen the 4.7 inch iPhone
was simply a no-go so that gave birth to
a new Apple that constantly tried to
offer what their Android Rivals offered
from large displays and wireless
charging to multiple camera lenses and
more recently in always on display so
that's how we got here but why a 6.9
inch display on the 16 Pro Max and why
now well if we're being completely
honest I think we've pretty much reached
Peak smartphone especially seeing as the
last three 6.7 inch display iPhones
don't really feel much different so
Apple doesn't really have a choice
they've got to make it even bigger and
even better and to tell you the truth
I'm actually pretty excited for the new
6.9 inch display but the biggest
takeaway is this only the Pro Models
will be getting the new display sizes
the regular ones are staying the same so
it's pretty clear Apple wants you to buy
Pro models and I completely agree
regular models aren't worth the price
compared to the pros and now let me
answer the last question of what else we
should expect from next year's 16 Pro
and 16 Pro Max but first I've got to
give a shout out to our partner case
coup for their magic stand case which is
the most versatile case I've ever used
due to the fact that it has a completely
flush Max safe ring on a hinge so you
can use it as a stand for things like
watching videos or taking photos at a
variety of angles in the case itself is
built super rugged and high quality as
well and now casu is offering a new
payment method so you can shop now and
pay overtime with clarna so check out
the discount info and Link down in the
description below now getting back to
what we should expect on the 16 Pro
Models one thing for sure is going to be
the delayed you unified volume button
now we got a lot of leaks about this
from unknowns 21 he basically showed us
renders of exactly what it's going to
look like with a really cool cut or
Ridge in the middle of the button to
kind of signify where the plus is and
where the minus is and make it easier to
use he also gave us the full internal
diagram what the actual part is going to
look like stretching from the volume
button to the action button and power
button all connected together but then
only about half an hour later he came
back and confirmed that it was
officially canceled or delayed until the
iPhone 16 pro and pro Max models now in
terms of other details made Chico many
months ago told us that there would be
three taptic motors or engines on the
iPhone 15 which is now delayed until
iPhone 16 Pro Models so basically you're
going to be using the action button and
the volume buttons and it's going to
feel like a real Click A lot of people
are not even going to know that their
actual solid state buttons similar to
how the touch ID button worked on the
home button like the iPhone se3 or the
magic Trackpad on the MacBooks it's not
really moving at all but when you click
it it feels like a real click and the
way you test this is by turning it off
then you feel that it's not actually
moving at all now apple is gonna have a
really cool solution for this with the
iPhone 16 Pro it's going to come with a
special low power chip that will allow
this to actually work while the phone is
off or in a very deep low battery mode
it's still gonna click which is
absolutely amazing and that's how it's
gonna work to continue to turn on or do
a hard reset on the iPhone if it's not
working now another thing thing that was
rumored to come to the 16 pro model next
year is the Periscope camera not only
just on the 15 Pro Max which is getting
it this year but apparently on both of
the models next year however we do have
a leak from Michiko and he completely
disagrees he says it's going to continue
to be exclusive on the 16 Pro Max model
and the idea here is that this Periscope
camera is going to be amazing it's going
to allow you to get up to 6 x Zoom but
it might even have adaptive Zoom
capability so imagine it can zoom from
3x to 6X dynamically and physically that
would be the dream because if it's 6X
only then you're going to be going from
1X with the main camera with a 2X punch
in digitally to 6X so that entire range
is not going to look as good but if it
can dynamically Zoom from 3x to 6X that
covers the entire range and it is going
to be amazing going further apple is
working on their own 5G modem chip to
replace the one from Qualcomm
specifically this year's iPhone 15 Pro
Models are getting the x70 modem which
is definitely more efficient but when
Apple makes their own it is going to be
on a whole another level because they
could potentially be using tsmc's latest
and greatest three nanometer tech for
those modems making them insanely
efficient and that should even help stop
iPhone display screen dimming which
happens a lot when you're using 5G
especially GPS at the same time so it's
going to be a lot more efficient and
there's even talks of Apple making their
own Wi-Fi and Bluetooth chips as well
which helps save Apple money and keeps
the price of the iPhones down now of
course everybody knows that we're
getting USBC ports on all of the iPhone
15 models this year but there's a chance
that Apple was planning to give the
iPhone 15 Pro Models Thunderbolt support
basically much faster ports but if it
doesn't come this year then I think
apple has a very good opportunity to
give it to the 16 Pro Models because if
you think about it there are enough
changes coming to the 15 Pro Models so
Apple can simply delay that one more
year to make it a nice little upgrade
and to finish off this video here are my
thoughts on if you should wait for this
16 Pro well personally I don't think so
because we are expecting so many changes
to the 15 pro this year including USBC
the new redesign that's going to have
rounded edges so it's going to feel
better and the new ultra slim bezels
amongst other features like the
Periscope camera so I think the 15 Pro
is actually going to be the perfect year
to to upgrade so with that said
hopefully you enjoyed these leaks and
rumors on the iPhone 16 Pro and if you
did click the circle above to subscribe
for more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
foreign